denise in just a few months short-term
rentals will be legal in unincorporated
clark county a new state mandate will
overturn a previous ban so local leaders
asked for public input about the new
regulations now in place sasha loftis
was at tonight's meeting joining us now
live in studio with the very latest
bryan short-term rentals have been a
contentious topic here in southern
nevada for a while but now the state is
requiring clark county to legalize them
so local leaders are really asking the
public to help them make this process as
smooth as possible
when it comes to short-term rentals
people in southern nevada are split we
just want to be able to live our lives
in peace this is my vacation home and
i'm hoping to be able to make some money
on the side right now these rentals are
illegal in clark county but that will
change come july 1st due to the nevada
legislature's passage of assembly bill
363 allowing rentals like airbnb or
verbo i believe a cul-de-sac is not
suitable for str that's why clark county
leaders have come up with an ordinance
to regulate them and held the latest of
many public meetings wednesday to get
feedback there are a lot of voices in
this conversation there are people on
every single side of this issue district
a commissioner michael naft shared a few
of the regulations set to take effect
like business license requirements a cap
of 16 people per property and homeowners
association consent this is about coming
up with some rational common sense ways
to
both do what the state required us to do
but the plan isn't set in stone yet so
he encourages anyone with a stake in
this to speak up i do think that there
are ways that they could tweak the law
currently written whether they're for or
against what comes next it comes with
responsibility and i don't think that's
going to happen
the current draft ordinance also
prevents people from using apartments
mobile homes or manufactured homes for
short-term rentals we have a look at the
whole thing right now on our website
eight news now dot com denise